[Music]
well good afternoon dear friends thank
you for joining us here
at this program i'd like to know a
question and answer program where
you send us your questions we do
research
and if there is an answer we try to
provide it
i want to give you the address where you
can send us your questions we have many
many of them that are
kind of backed up but the address is
tv at some tv dot org
once again tv at some tv
dot org so make sure you send us your
questions to that electronic address
and we will do everything possible to
answer them uh we have with me pastor
daniel gouveia
uh we appreciate you taking the time to
be with us
uh he's the pastor of one of the large
largest churches here in central
california conference
uh lots of work to do but he takes a few
minutes
uh to come to secrets unsealed and we do
appreciate it pastor
thank you for the invitation it's a
pleasure to be here praise the lord
would you have prayer for us and then
we'll get into our questions certainly
let us pray
father in heaven thank you so much for
the great
great gift we have in your written word
the bible thank you that you give us
this
opportunity and privilege to come
together and answer these questions
i pray that the holy spirit may guide
our minds and
the minds and hearts of every listener
we pray these things in the name of
jesus amen
amen well we have several interesting
questions today
and the first one says as follows
why do as per the spirit of prophecy in
early writings 39.2
why do angels need or use a golden card
to enter and leave heaven that's a great
question
i have to i have to confess that before
this question i hadn't given it much
thought but i did
research a little bit and i found these
two main quotes where
alan white i believe there are the only
two quotes where ellen white talks about
this
and yes here in early writing space 39
we have
um a section of the book or a chapter
where she is speaking about god's love
for his people
and she talks about angels going up and
down and protecting the people of god
she says how they are happy when we make
the right decisions and
how they are sad and even weep when
we make wrong decisions and then she
says there is perfect
order and harmony in the holy city again
this is early writing space 39
all the angels that are commissioned to
visit
the earth hold a golden
card which they present to the angels
at the gates of the city as they pass
and now this isn't
the interesting thing as they pass in
and out meaning it's not only something
they need to present when they are
getting into
the golden city but when they are going
out when they are going in
they present this card heaven is a good
place i long to be there
and behold my lovely jesus who gave his
life for me
and be changing to his glorious image
oh for language to express the glory of
the bright world to come
i versed for the living streams that
make glad the city of our god now
she saw it i did not see it and i durst
and i long for it as well but
my main thing here in this quote and
even the following where she mentions
the gold
card is she is talking about themes that
are
so high and so important that
this this golden card doesn't seem to be
something that she really
expounds or gives much attention to but
i think we can say one or two things
about it
now the second quote is on christian
experience and teachings of
ellen du white she writes in page
101 then my attending angel directed me
to the city again
where i saw four angels winging their
way to the gate of the city
they were just presenting the golden
card
to the angel at the gate when i saw
another angel flying
swiftly from the direction of the most
excellent glory and crying with a loud
voice to the other angels
and waving something up and down in his
hand
i asked my attending angel for an
explanation of what i saw
he told me that i could see no more then
but he would shortly show me what those
things um
uh what those things that i then saw
meant
so these are the only two expressions we
have
in her writings of this golden card what
is it
well i don't know if i can give a very
detailed
answer we do have in the bible and i
think the bible really should guide our
our thoughts here
we have in the bible many passages
malachi 3 16 i'm just going to quote
tell them
psalm 56 8 revelation 20 verse 12
and others and my favorite daniel
chapter 7
verse 9 and 10 talks about
books in heaven we know that there are
books in heaven there are records in
heaven
uh the the actions of human beings are
recorded
in heaven and there is actually
books and then the bible also speaks
about the book of life
so there are records in heaven and
why do you have those records there god
knows everything
he has no memory problems right
but according to the bible heaven and
the universe that god created
is a place that has millions and
millions of creatures
not only human beings but intelligent
beings like the angels and
inhabitants of other worlds that god
created
and that are looking intently at this
story of the great controversy how it is
being played out here on earth
so here in the in daniel chapter seven
like i said this is my favorite
uh verse or or passage that speaks about
books
says talks about verse 9 i watched till
thrones were put in place and the
ancient of days was seated
his garment was white as snow and the
hair of his head was like pure wool
his throne was a fiery flame hits wheels
a burning fire
a fiery stream issued and came forth
from before him
a thousand thousands ministered to him
ten
thousand times ten thousand stood before
him
the court was seated and the books were
opened now traditionally the seventh-day
adventist church has interpreted
this vision as the start of the judgment
in 1844 and i embrace
that vision and interpretation
completely
but it is interesting to see that in the
judgment of god in heaven
there are many angels who are the
witnesses to this judgment
um the the character of god is
at stake because satan has brought many
accusations against god
and there are records the angels have
records
records that they actually helped to
make
to to to build
and could it be that this golden card is
just the angels showing the record of
what
of their missions and and what happens
in the life of human beings how they
accept and how they reject the the mercy
of god and the interventions of god in
their lives
seems to be especially in the first
quote early writings
because almighty is speaking exactly
about that how
angels report to the lord and to the
other angels in heaven
the decisions that the people of god are
making here on earth
so maybe what we have here is
that when the angel leaves the city and
presents the card
they're actually showing what their
commission is yes
and then when they come back they have
the card and maybe they've already
written some things on it saying
mission accomplished right but we don't
know for sure exactly
but i don't think that it's a
salvational issue
uh i think the key is that there is
perfect order and harmony in the holy
city that's why god operates
heaven in that way and particularly the
city
so an interesting question um now we
have another one this is um
probably going to take us a little bit
longer
how is it explained that the events of
66 through 70 a.d
which is the siege and the destruction
of jerusalem
are part of the 70-week prophecy as they
did not transpire
during its chronology because the
chronology of the 70 weeks ends
in 34 a.d but the siege and destruction
is outside that time frame so how do we
explain that
well that's a that's a very good
question um and
just to put it in context let's go to
daniel chapter nine and
it's interesting to read the verses
24 through 27
and especially verse 26 it says 70 weeks
are determined for your people
and for your holy city to finish the
transgression to make an end of sins to
make reconciliation for iniquity to
bring in everlasting righteousness
to seal up vision and prophecy and to
anoint the most
holy now we see of course we could
highlight many things but here in verse
24 it's saying
that these 70 weeks are determined for
your people and for your holy city so it
had to do with the jewish people
especially
and then it says verse 25 know therefore
and understand that from the going forth
of the command to restore and build
jerusalem until messiah the prince there
shall be seven weeks
and 62 weeks so 69 weeks in total
the street shall be built again and the
wall even in trouble sometimes
so you have here the first seven weeks
referring to the rebuilding of jerusalem
that took approximately 49 years and
then the rest of the time until we get
to
year 27 a.d when jesus becomes
the anointed because he was filled with
the holy spirit
um at his baptism the holy spirit
anointed him
and then verse 26 says and after the 62
weeks meaning the 7 plus 62 so
uh after the 69 weeks we know
by the rest of prophecy was at the
middle of the last week
messiah shall be cut off but not for
himself
and now comes the interesting part and
the people of the prince who
is to come shall destroy the city
and the sanctuary the end of it shall be
with a flood
until the end of the war desolations are
determined then it says verse 27 then he
shall confirm a covenant with many for
one week
but in the middle of the week he shall
bring an end to sacrifice and offering
since we are dealing with 70 weeks of
years 70 weeks
7 70 prophetic weeks of course this
this week that is mentioned in uh
verse 27 has to be the last week in the
in the middle of the last week
the messiah would make the offering
to cease to sacrifice an offering it
would bring it to an end
we know that when jesus died the veil of
the temple was torn in two from top to
bottom
so we believe that in the middle of the
week exactly in the spring of 31 a.d the
passover time jesus the true lamb of god
was sacrificed
now it is interesting even though in the
70 weeks we have that
um that period of time ending then later
in the 30
34 a.d like you mentioned in the autumn
when stephen is stoned
we have that chronology there but it is
interesting that still
in verse 26 it talks about the
destruction of
the city and it says it puts it in the
future and the people of the prince who
is to come
shall destroy the city and the sanctuary
the end of it
shall be with a flood so the date of the
destruction of the city is not given
for what i can see but it is mentioned
that the city would be destroyed
somehow god is giving daniel the hint
that things would not go very well for
the jewish people and that eventually
the city of jerusalem would be destroyed
many years later
not in the time of daniel not as he was
fearing
but many years later even after the end
of the 70 weeks
well the prophecy itself shows that the
destruction of jerusalem
falls outside the parameters of the 70
weeks
reading again verse 27 there's two key
words here
then he shall confirm a covenant with
many for one week
that's the last week yes but in the
middle of the week that is of the last
week
he shall bring an end to sacrifice and
offering
and then it says on the wing of
abominations
shall be one who makes desolate now
where else in the bible do we find those
two words
abomination and desolate yeah you go to
matthew 24
so so it is the destruction of jerusalem
is contemplated not in the chronology
but as an event as a consequence
of the the jewish nation not accepting
the terms of the covenant
because in matthew 24 it says therefore
when you see the abomination of
desolation there's the same two key
words
and it says spoken of by daniel the
prophet yes
standing in the holy place whoever reads
let him understand and then the
comparison in luke 21
tells us that it's the roman armies that
surround the city uh
21 20 says but when you see jerusalem
surrounded by
armies then know that its desolation is
near
so the word desolation once again is a
key word
that you find in daniel chapter 9. so
i think the answer to this question is
that
even though the destruction of jerusalem
does not fall within the parameters
of the 70 weeks it is the result of what
happened during the 70 weeks that's the
rejection of the messiah by the jewish
yeah and there's a further thing also
and that is that
that even after uh the jewish nation
um was actually rejected as a theocracy
god still extended mercy to individuals
yes
uh within the jewish nation if we can
read matthew 23
matthew chapter 23 god bears long yes
so in matthew chapter 23
and verse 34
jesus is speaking to the scribes and
pharisees and he's going to say
i'm still going to send you messengers
and this is what you're going to do to
um could you read those verses yes
therefore indeed i send you prophets
wise men and scribes some of them you
will kill
and crucify and some of them you will
scourge in your synagogues
and persecute from city to city okay
stop there just a minute
uh this is future from this time yes
jesus saying
you know he's saying in the future i'm
going to send you wise men
prophets and scribes
some of them you're going to kill some
of them you will crucify
some of them you will scourge in your
synagogues and some of them you will
persecute
from city of the city which was saul
saul of tarsus
and then verse 35 that on you
may come all the righteous bloodshed on
the earth
from the blood of righteous abel to the
blood of zechariah
son of barakaya whom you murdered
between the temple and the altar
assuredly i say to you
all these things will come upon this
generation
and if i could read a statement here
from great controversy 27 and 28
ellen white wrote for nearly 40 years
after the doom of jerusalem this after
the doom of jerusalem
had been pronounced by christ himself
the lord delayed his judgments
upon the city and the nation that's why
40 years pass
wonderful was the long suffering of god
towards the rejecters of his gospel
and the murderers of his son the parable
of the unfruitful tree represented god's
dealings with the jewish nation
the command had gone forth cut it down
why come breath hit the ground
but divine mercy had spared it yet a
little longer
there were still many among the jews who
were ignorant
of the character and the work of christ
and the children had not enjoyed the
opportunities or received the light
which their parents had spurned
through the preaching of the apostles
and their associates this is
matthew 23 that we just read god would
cause
light to shine upon them they would be
permitted to see how prophecy had been
fulfilled
not only in the birth and life of christ
but in his death and resurrection
the children were not condemned for the
sins of the parents
but when with the knowledge of all the
light given to their parents
the children rejected the additional
light granted to themselves
they became partakers of the parents
since and
filled up the measure of their iniquity
and of course the destruction of
jerusalem ensued yes so
it's amazing to see how god is so
merciful and even
though the people of israel as a nation
rejected the messiah
and even though we come to the end of
the 70 weeks and
the gospel is now taken to the world and
whoever believes in jesus becomes the
spiritual
israel but still god did not forget the
jewish nation and mercy is still
available to
any jew as to any other human being
well okay well i think we've answered
that one
um let's go to this one this one is
interesting
um pastor i'm from the philippines i've
never been to the philippines but i know
that the
church is growing exponentially there
the lay people are very much involved in
winning souls amen
uh here's the question i'd like to know
what is the uncovering
of feet what does that mean of course
it's in the book of roots
right yes that's a very interesting
question
and um i think the best thing
that we can do is actually read the
passage in root
chapter three and let's go there
um this is when root
ruth um is given the council
by her mother-in-law naomi to
ask boaz basically this is what she was
doing
asked boaz to marry her
and she did it in a way that sounds
awkward to us but it was something that
was very well accepted in the
culture of the time so versus one i i
actually like to read a little bit
uh more than just the verse so we can
have an idea of the story
then naomi her mother-in-law said to her
my daughter shall i not seek security
for you that it may be well with you
now boaz whose young woman you were with
is he not our relative in fact he is
winnowing barley tonight at the
threshing floor
therefore wash yourself and anoint
yourself put on your best garment and go
down to the threshing floor
but do not make yourself known to the
man until he has
finished eating and drinking then it
shall be
when he lies down that you shall notice
the place where he lies
and you shall go in uncover his feet
here's the expression
and lie down and he will tell you
what you should do and she said to her
all that you say to me i will do so
that's
exactly what she did she waited for boaz
to finish eating and drinking
boss went to lie down and
as he was already lying down he covered
his feet which was
normal in that time people would just
sleep in their
clothes that they would use during the
day many times especially when they were
working out in the country and they
would cover their feet so their
extremities
wouldn't be cold and he covered his feet
with a mantle or something
and she took the position of somebody
who comes uncovers the feet takes
part of that mantle and even puts the
mantle over herself a little bit
because we see that he he
moves during the night the bible says at
midnight
he was startled to see that there was a
woman lying at his feet
and he he asked who are you verse 9.
so she answered i am ruth your
maidservant
take your maidservant under your wing
for you are a close relative or a go l a
redeemer
so basically her action was highly
symbolic she was asking
put your your your mantle over me
basically marrying me take me into your
family because
my my husband is deceased and you are
the close relative
which in israel at that time was a duty
to the close relative
right to marry the wife of the deceased
and to
bring up a descendants to the person who
is deceased now
when we continue reading we see that
when
boaz sees that ruth is making the
request
for for him to marry her he says
something
interesting of course he's going to
mention that there's somebody that is
closer than i am i'm going to ask him if
he wants to take you or not
if not i will i will perform the duty
of a close relative to you but there's
something that i like
he says verse 11. and now my daughter do
not fear
i will do for you all that you request
for all the people of my town know that
you
are a virtuous woman
now i think the main issue with this
passage is
we need to trust fully that ruth did not
do
anything that was not culturally
appropriate
she did not do anything that was immoral
she did something that was perfectly
acceptable
and she was a virtuous woman so she
would not do anything
that would put her reputation or the
reputation of boaz at stake
i found this interesting statement that
is in perfect harmony
with what you're saying this is from the
great
presbyterian bible commentary
i think he's presbyterian adam clark's
commentary
and this is what he wrote about this
custom
it is said that women the east when
going to bed of their lawful husbands
through modesty
and in token of subject subjection go to
the
bed's foot and gently raising the
clothes
creep under them up to their place
on the whole we must say had not boast
been a person
of extraordinary piety prudence
incontinence
this experiment might have been fatal to
ruth right
we cannot easily account for this
transaction
probably naomi knew more than she
revealed
to her daughter-in-law the experiment
however was dangerous
and should in no sense be imitated
so so by climbing under the cover so to
speak
she's um i wouldn't say
um she was overtly
telling boaz hey boys uh let's get there
yeah
exactly and it's interesting the
reaction of boaz verse
10 says blessed are you of the lord my
daughter
for you have shown more kindness at the
end
than at the beginning and that you did
not go after young men
whether poor or rich meaning boaz was
probably not as young
as ruth and boaz was apparently
single and ruth was
seeking for him to marry her which was
the right thing to do because
he was one of the close relatives and
she was
not going after the wild pleasures of
her youth
she because she was probably still young
even though she was a widow
but she was really trying to do the
right thing and following naomi's advice
i think boaz was really happy that she
took that
that step so he was happy
she was accepting also of her
mother-in-law's
advice and we saw if we see that they
became
um parents of someone that was then
in the line that from where david came
so
and ultimately the messiah yes you know
so god
god works in mysterious ways so
basically
what this verse is dealing with in the
book of ruth chapter 3 and verse 4
is a cultural custom yes of the day
which we don't practice today yes we
don't practice today some commentators
say that
servants would lie at the feet of their
masters
and would take a little bit of the
mantle of their masters and cover
themselves with it
that was something appropriate and
cultural
well i don't know if we have
all the the information today about
exactly those customs and how things
worked
but definitely she was asking boaz to
marry him
and she did not do anything that was
reprehensible
boaz was understood her
intentions clearly and said all the town
of my people know that you are a
virtuous woman
a virtuous woman would not do anything
immoral
we cannot take this text and apply it to
any situation where we want to
say well you know even boaz and ruth
spent the night together before they
were married
you cannot do that i'm sorry you know
both she and he were persons
of moral integrity exactly and this
simply reflects the custom of the time
well we don't have time for another
question
i want to thank everybody for joining us
i do have good news
you've noticed that c.a murray hasn't
been here for about five months
because he's had issues in panama his
mother-in-law
is 101 years old she's an ill health and
irma has had some health issues as well
and
he's had trouble getting his ticket back
to the u.s because of covid
so it's been a real ordeal for them but
i have good news
i got a text message from ca and he will
be joining us
lord willing on june 3. so once again he
will be with us and then pastor goway if
it's okay with you we'll have a
threesome oh that's okay
and we'll be able to answer many of your
questions thank you once again for
joining us
please send us your questions god bless
you and we hope to see you next time on
this program
i'd like to know
[Music]
you